foreign
[Music]
media is running with a poll which is
supposed to show that women are
oppressed in the workplace but instead
it manages to prove something else CNBC
reports there's a major confidence gap
between men and women in the workplace
though it might not be in the way that
you'd expect a majority 64 of women
think they can do their manager's job
better than them versus 47 of men who
believe the same according to a monster
survey of 6847 workers conducted a Fri
on February that perspective doesn't
necessarily reflect that women feel
proficient in their jobs but rather that
they feel undervalued and overlooked for
management roles
according to monster career expert Vicki
salami salimi salami tells a CNBC quote
women feel they can do their manager's
job she says but the frustration is why
aren't they given the opportunity to do
it
um
why aren't you giving the opportunity to
do your manager's job well because your
manager is doing it that might be the
reason
do you think your manager should just be
fired on the spot so they can try you
out for the role and even if they do
even if they fire your manager and
replace him with a woman why should you
why should you specifically be the woman
who takes his place
would you be satisfied if another woman
was promoted and not you
it's actually it's a statistical
certainty that many of the women who
said they could do their manager's job
better many of them have managers who
are women so if a woman is promoted over
a woman that's an example of sexism
against women how does this work exactly
see this is one of the many fundamental
problems with the claims of sexism and
oppression against women in the
workplace
the women who are inclined to make these
kinds of complaints will still make them
even if their management team is already
dominated by women as it is in many
companies
have you ever known a feminist to say
well I didn't get this opportunity but
another woman did and so I'm happy this
is a win for The Sisterhood they might
claim to have that attitude but none of
us have ever encountered it in real life
I certainly haven't
so often when a member of an allegedly
marginalized group complains about
discrimination
they're really complaining about how
they personally have been treated or how
they perceive themselves to have been
treated
it is a selfish complaint disguised as
concerned for the group
but then you quickly discover that this
person will take no comfort in finding
out that other people in the group
aren't having those experiences so when
they say don't treat us this way
what they really mean is don't treat me
this way
and that might seem like an obvious
thing to point out but it's it is it's
it's an important distinction because
it's a very different sort of complaint
whether it's true or not that they're
being mistreated you know and often it's
not true but whether it's true or not
still it's worth noting the nature of
the complaint which is usually personal
and self-centered
bringing it back to women in the
workplace the fact is that women are
being promoted women are getting
opportunities and if anything in big
corporations at least they're getting
more opportunities than men these
companies are actively looking to staff
their management teams with anyone other
than white males they have a vested
interest in doing that
but the women who still complain about a
sexist conspiracy to Rob them of
opportunities they aren't likely to take
any solace in the fact that other women
are in fact getting promoted that's
because again the women who say you're
being unfair to women
who says that is often really saying
you're being unfair to me
doesn't really care about women in
general she cares about herself which is
fine y'all gotta look out for number one
but at least be honest about it this is
perfectly evidenced by the career expert
Vicki in the CNBC article saying that
women aren't getting the chance to do
their managers jobs
regardless of the fact that many of
these women have managers who are women
it turns out that uh you know the women
making the complaint don't want a woman
to be manager they want themselves
personally to be manager
which again is different
back to the article women are far less
likely to say that they feel they get
the same quantity and quality of
opportunities as men in the workplace 66
percent of men believe everyone at work
gets the same access to Opportunities
versus just 23 percent of women
according to monster the opportunities
Gap has a compounding effect among women
at levels at all levels in the workplace
women say that having a Clear Vision for
the future of their career is a top
priority for them and a lack of
potential advancement is the biggest red
flag that would lead them to turn down a
job offer
so the poll finds that a majority of
women
complain that the company they work for
is unfair and biased while also claiming
that they can do jobs that they have not
been judged qualified for
if you were trying to come up with a
poll to convince employers to hire men
instead of women I don't think you could
you could have done a better job than
this
though some of this polls supposed to
motivate Employers in the opposite
direction like you know hey women are
likely to have an inflated sense of
importance and also complain a lot now
hire more of them
that seems to be the sales pitch and
it's not my sales pitch by the way I'm
not saying that I'm telling you that's
what the survey apparently says
now to what extent it actually reflects
the the opinion of the majority of women
I don't know
those are the services
the article ends this way some 77 of men
believe everyone is paid the same
presumably they mean paid the same for
the same work versus 24 of women
concerning concerning given that women
say fair and equal wages is the number
one most important benefit to them in
the workplace the gender wage gap which
has persisted for decades now sits at
the average woman being paid 82 cents
for every dollar paid to a man according
to the Census Bureau the gap widens for
many women of color
now of course we couldn't conclude this
without the trusty old wage Gap myth if
you're curious the the article supports
the women get paid 82 cents for every
dollar that a man earns Claim by linking
to a fact sheet on the census.gov
website which tells us that the median
earnings of men are about fifty seven
thousand dollars a year this is back in
2019. while the median for women is
around forty seven thousand
these are the numbers
that you get if you take all of the men
in every profession and throw them into
one pot all of the women in every
profession throw them into another and
then compare the two
but that comparison is totally
meaningless as it obviously doesn't take
into account things like hours worked
overtime experience skill effort
qualifications career choice Etc
it doesn't even bother to compare men
and women in the same industry let alone
the same positions within those
Industries
instead it effectively Compares you know
male commercial airline pilots to female
hairdresser dressers and male surgeons
to a female daycare workers and so on it
makes an even one-to-one comparison
among all these groups
it is in fact a perfect example of how
you lie with Statistics because the
figure they end up with 82 cents on the
dollar
is technically true if you don't control
for any meaningful factors whatsoever
but they never mention that detail when
they cite the figure
which makes it effectively a lie
so
what is the real takeaway here
what can we learn from the fact that
according to the survey majority of
women in the workforce feel that they're
being oppressed and being treated
unfairly because of their sex
well we learned just that that it's a
Feeling this is what the oppression
narrative is ultimately grounded in it's
something that people feel something
that they are indeed encouraged to feel
these are feelings instilled and
fostered in them
the poll says that a majority of women
believe they feel that they aren't
getting equal opportunities
very much in the same way that uh so
many people believe feel you know the
wage Gap
we aren't supposed to ever ask is
whether these beliefs and feelings
actually reflect reality
that's because we do investigate that
question we will find out very often and
very quickly that they just simply don't
and that's why not all women in the
workforce but at least the majority who
took this poll
are today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]